so in order to try to defend himself
Republican Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker went on Sean Hannity's
Fox news program last night
and this is all about this explosive
story wherein although for months and
months and months Herschel Walker has
been saying I'm pro-life no exceptions
for rape incestor health of the mother
never never ever ever an abortion it's a
murder and now we have learned that
Herschel Walker allegedly paid for a
woman's abortion after urging her to get
one when she became pregnant during
their relationship some years ago so
Sean Hannity goes into rescue mode and
as you know Sean Hannity has tried to
rescue Trump in these interviews and it
hasn't gone particularly well here Sean
Hannity tries to help Herschel Walker
and it goes really really poorly now the
funny thing about the interview is
it's almost impossible to even tell
whether Herschel Walker is denying the
story because he's so incoherent but if
you I'm kind of kidding like if you
listen carefully he does deny it here
he's asked by Sean Hannity do you know
the woman in question and he says I have
no idea
he has no idea whether he knows her and
then he goes to talk about the Border
it's beyond parody start with The Daily
Beast Herschel I mean serious
accusations that in 2009 that you paid
for an abortion first question do you
know the woman that is making this
allegation
I have no idea no idea but it is a
flight out lie and he has no idea
whether he knows her uh and now you know
how important this seat is the seat is
very important that they'll do anything
to win this seat lie because they want
to make it by everything else except for
the true problems that we have in this
country is this inflation the board are
wide open Crime they don't want to talk
about that so they're making up lies now
because they need this Georgia seat
right I want to encourage anyone out
there let's not let them take this seat
go go and vote yeah that's this is the
the entire story really is about the
fact that Democrats want the Border wide
open and this is how they're going to
achieve it
um Herschel Walker then asked about
whether he sent the money and he says I
send money to a lot of people I just
like to help people then he says he
doesn't really know anything about it
and then a picture of the signed card
pops up on the screen every minute
element of this rescue interview attempt
just going wrong for Herschel Walker
because right now for them to come out
with total lies I think that's nice to
us so they're claiming that on September
12th of 2009 that the woman has a
receipt for an abortion they're claiming
that five days later on September 17th
you sent a 700 check and that you sent
it in a get well card the get well card
it looks like it's included with your
signature on in the article have you
seen it and is that your signature
uh I haven't seen it uh it's on the
screen now maybe he can't see the screen
you know I can tell you uh I send out so
many get well or send out so much of
anything but I can tell you right now he
sends out so much of anything before we
continue I love how Hannity is is like
listing all the evidence begrudgingly
yeah he's like listen Herschel they've
got the bank transfer receipts and
they've got uh the get well card and it
looks like it's your handwriting and
they also have the receipt from the
abortion and they have pictures of you
on dates with the woman and they have
you in an audio recording urging her to
get an abortion no this stuff isn't true
is it Herschel it can't possibly be true
I never asked anyone to get an abortion
I never pay for an abortion and it's a
lie and I'm going to continue to fight
you know yeah I'll tell you that's what
they want they want this seat but right
now they've energized me even more and
they're not going to take the seat so
they better work it even harder because
they've jeopardized my kids they've
jeopardized my family they think they
can threaten me they think they can
scare me right now all that done is it's
energized me more that I'm gonna fight
and win this seat for the great people
of Joy all right so anyway not exactly
great uh Alibis here from Herschel
Walker but a wild wild story and just
completely failing I mean listen if you
found that convincing let me know it's
it's not seeming particularly convincing
to me but let me know if you found it
convincing and this is only one of two
Herschel Walker scandals in the last 24
hours
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save twenty percent with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below